protéger ses proches financièrement
après sa disparition c'est possible
notamment avec l'assurance décès prenons
l'exemple d'un assuré qui souscrit un
contrat d'une garantie de 100 mille
euros pour dix ans ils paient une prime
mensuelle et en contrepartie l'assureur
est en charge de la gestion du dossier
en cas de décès avant la clôture du
contrat les cent mille euros sont versés
aux héritiers disons que pour une
personne qui a 40 ans qui veut se
garantir pour cent mille euros
en amont nous sommes dans des primes qui
sont relativement modestes on est à 30
35 euros par mois
après si on veut un million d'euros et
si on a 50 ans on peut tout de suite
monté à des 100 ou 150 euros par mois
les inconvénients c'est que c'est à
fonds perdus donc il faut vraiment que
le décès se fasse durant la durée du
contrat
l' avantage c'est que ça permet de
donner aux héritiers une somme pour
continuer à vivre et ne pas réduire leur
train de vie
autre produit financier transmis en cas
de décès l'assurance vie le principe
épargner un capital avec deux
possibilités pour l'assurer première
solution un investissement dans un fonds
sécurisés principalement composée de
dette française la rentabilité dépend
alors de l'évolution des taux d'intérêts
deuxième possibilité il peut choisir des
fonds profilés avec un mélange de titres
financiers de type actions ou
obligations avec un niveau de bénéfice
un certain en fonction du marché ce qui
est un petit peu dommage c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les taux des fonds en
euros ont beaucoup baissé puisque on
donne à peu près 2 % de rendement et
qu'on essaye donc donc pour un petit peu
relancé ce rendement de mélanger les
fonds en euros avec des fonds en unités
de compte et des fonds profilés hervé
rocheteau dirige le service succession
d'une banque basée à montigny le
bretonneux
il intervient après le décès des
personnes assurées différentes
vérifications l'acte de décès les
documents notariaux l'identité des
héritiers et parfois des certificats
médicaux son rôle accompagner les
proches du défunt
alors elle est décédée le 25 août les
sommes en jeu sont supérieurs à 150
mille euros en ce qui concerne l'
ensemble de l' épargne et pour les
presser un peu moins de 50 euros
le prêt était assurée justement par le
biais des nations à ce décès ce qui
permettra je dois de les libérer de ce
prêt et ils vont pouvoir conserver toute
l'épargné
c'était l'intérêt de l'assurance décès
dans ce cas là il y a de l'assurance vie
avec plusieurs contrats des contrats
avec des clauses standard c'est à dire
personne de nommer et des contrats sur
lesquels au contraire il y à des enfants
ou des petits enfants qui sont nommés
qui vont pouvoir être réglé très
rapidement
généralement sous un mois donc on fait
vraiment au plus vite
lors des neuf premiers mois de 2010 est
les sociétés d'assurances ont collecté
80 17,3 milliards d'euros de cotisations
mensuelles pour l'assurance vie
ce type de produit reste le placement
préféré des français 43% d'entre eux
choisissent cette épargne selon un
sondage au doxa linxea devant le livret
a ou le pel